James Bowie is a man today known primarily
for two things- his participation in the Battle
of the Alamo and a large knife design that
bears his name.
It’s impossible to separate fact from legend
concerning an amazing amount of this American
folk hero’s life, owing to Bowie leaving
exceptionally little in the way of a paper
trail documenting the events of his life and
the fact that contemporary news articles about
him are conflicting in their reports.
That said, concerning the topic at hand today,
we do definitively know how the style of knife
now known as a “Bowie” knife got the name
and how it was popularised.
It all started in 1826 when Bowie and his
brother Rezin were staying in Alexandria,
Louisiana.
In the years leading up to this, the brothers
operated an illegal foreign slave trade business
in which they’d acquire foreign slaves from
Jean Laffitte, who in turn had acquired these
unfortunate individuals via capturing slave
ships traveling through the Gulf of Mexico
and the Caribbean.
The brother’s profit from this slave smuggling
scheme supposedly made them almost $65,000
(about $1.1 million today) in the two years
they were involved in it before moving on
to land speculation.
This brings us back to 1826 in which James
was in need of a loan for a business deal-
a loan that one Norris Wright, banker and
sheriff in Rapides Parish, Louisiana, denied
the frontiersman.
It is widely reported that there was bad blood
between the two owing to Bowie previously
supporting Norris’ opponent in the election
to become sheriff.
Later, Bowie and Wright seem to have gotten
in a physical tussle, with Wright drawing
his pistol and shooting at the unarmed Bowie.
The bullet missed, but various accounts claimed
Bowie then lunged at Norris and the two fought
hand to hand.
Ultimately Bowie had to be pulled off of Wright
lest he kill him.
But, again, at the risk of being a bit of
a broken record, so much of Bowie’s history
lacks any sort of definitive primary documents
to back up these stories, and even first hand
accounts, when available on some aspects of
his life, are often contradictory.
So whether this is exactly how it happened
or not isn’t clear.
The real point here is that the pair most
definitely didn’t like each other, partially
leading to a more famous incident to come
between the two, which gave us the name “Bowie
knife”.
After the fight, Bowie was given what was
essentially an overly thick butcher’s knife
by his brother for protection.
This was a knife Rezin would later claim in
a letter that he had custom made, reportedly
forged by Louisiana blacksmith Jesse Clifft.
At this point, you might be wondering why
Bowie would want to carry that knife around
and not a gun.
It’s important to remember here that flintlock
pistols of the age were notoriously unreliable
for a variety of reasons, so a knife was sometimes
preferred in relatively close quarter fighting.
In fact, it was partially the unreliability
of sidearms at the time that led to so many
people wanting a Bowie knife, and later why
its popularity diminished rapidly when more
reliable hand guns, like the Colt pistol,
became available to the masses.
In any event, in 1827, a friend of Bowie’s,
Samuel L. Wells III, was set to duel a prominent
Louisiana native known as Dr. Thomas H. Maddox.
Both men were known to be mostly friendly
with one another, but relations between their
respective families were heated, with things
eventually escalating to honour needing to
be satisfied.
Thus various duels were fought between the
sides, including this one.
At the time, anti-dueling laws were in effect
in the region, so the men arranged to shoot
at each other on a small island in the middle
of the Mississippi river, where they assumed
state jurisdiction didn’t apply.
Supporting each man was a contingent of friends
and witnesses, some of whom had themselves
previously dueled or otherwise come to blows
with each other.
Notable here is that one of them was the aforementioned
enemy of Bowie’s, Norris Wright, who supported
Maddox in the duel.
Taking place on September 19, 1827, the actual
duel itself ended without any bloodshed; both
Wells and Maddox missed their agreed upon
number of shots.
With that, the pair resolved to end the duel
with a handshake, honour having been satisfied.
Up to this point, we can be reasonable confident
the details are accurate from surviving news
accounts.
What happened next, however, is much less
clear.
While there are numerous newspaper accounts
covering what would be called the “Sandbar
Fight”, for legal and personal bias reasons,
as well as possibly just notoriously inaccurate
human memory, the participants of the event
would later tell contradictory stories, and
even impartial observers’ accounts differ.
So take the details on the next bit with a
grain of salt- the important thing in terms
of the topic at hand today, the Bowie knife,
is simply the general event and Bowie’s
use of the knife in it.
After the shots were fired, it seems the two
men shook hands, but tempers flared between
Wells’ contingent and Maddox’s and a fight
broke out.
In subsequent news accounts, it appears that
Bowie was a central target for Maddox’s
side’s men, with it later being speculated
that this was because “they considered him
the most dangerous man among their opposition.”
However, it should also be noted that Bowie
wasn’t exactly the type of man who endeared
himself well to others for various reasons,
including somewhat unscrupulous business practices-
the bottom line being that Wright wasn’t
the only one who loathed him.
So they may have simply targeted Bowie particularly
in the fight because they just really didn’t
like him and thought this was a great opportunity
to kill him without getting into too much
trouble with the law.
Whatever the case, Judge R.A.
Crane drew his pistol and shot at the frontiersman,
hitting him in the hip, then later let loose
a second shot that missed and killed an unarmed
innocent bystander, Dr. Samuel Cuney.
Bowie then got up and charged at the judge,
at which point the judge used the gun to club
Bowie on the head, knocking him down once
again.
It was at this point that Wright took the
opportunity of his hated foe lying on the
ground to rush him with his cane sword, stabbing
Bowie straight through the chest.
With sword through his body, Bowie then grabbed
at Norris and pulled him to the ground.
Using the knife he was about to make famous
world-wide, he violently disemboweled Wright.
His nemesis dead, it was then reported that
Bowie once again joined the rest of the Wells’
party attacking the Maddox contingent.
Using a whirlwind of knife slashes, he seriously
wounded one Alfred Blanchard while his brother
ineffectually shot and then stabbed Bowie
some more.
During the estimated 90 second brawl, according
to the physicians’ reports, Bowie sustained
about a dozen serious wounds from various
attacks, including having been shot and stabbed
multiple times.
After the melee ended, the physicians present
attended to the wounded, including Bowie and,
miraculously, he survived.
Shortly thereafter, the “Sandbar Fight”
was national news, and Bowie’s exploits
in it became the stuff of legend.
Most pertinent to the topic at hand, reports
tended to focus on the “large butcher’s
knife”, as it was described by one witness,
Bowie used in the fight.
In the months following the brawl, blacksmiths
across the country were being asked by hunters
and other men to make them a knife “like
the one Bowie used”- a general knife design
that was good to passable in use in knife
fighting, eating, chopping, and various uses
in hunting, such as skinning and carving up
animals.
In fact, within a few years of the fight,
even blacksmiths across the pond in England
are known to have started producing similar
blades known as “Bowie” knives.
The term “Swiss Army Knife” was coined
by United States soldiers after WWII.
The soldiers had trouble pronouncing the original
name of “Schweizer Offiziersmesser” (Swiss
Officer’s Knife) and thus began calling
the multi-tool a “Swiss Army Knife”.
The company that makes Swiss Army Knives is
Victorinox, named after the founder, Karl
Elsener’s, deceased mother, Victoria.
The “nox” part comes from the fact that
stainless steel is also known as “inox”,
which is short for the French term “inoxydable”.
Karl Elsener himself was originally the owner
of a surgical equipment company.
He later took over production of the original
Modell 1890 knives, which were previously
made in Germany.
He moved the production to Switzerland and
greatly improved the design of the original
multi-tool.
His big breakthrough came when he figured
out a way to put blades on both sides of the
handle using the same spring to hold both
sides in place.
This allowed him to put twice as many features
into the multi-tool as was previously possible.